entire families in southern Mexico are
fleeing their homes over worsening
violence this Mass displacement of
mainly indigenous communities in the
state of chapas is being driven by a
deadly conflict between Waring factions
of the caloa and halisco New Generation
drug cartels each vying for control of
the people and their territory many say
this is just the latest chapter of
violence that's been playing out for
years know
for at least two and a half years chapas
has witnessed a dispute between the
large organized drug cartels who
maintain a rivalry over control of both
the routes of Transit and of course
territorial
[Music]
control this week tensions Rose even
further when villagers of the noeva Amed
Township clashed with members of the
Mexican military in one video a soldier
can be heard calling villagers cowards
for not standing standing up to the
cartel members
themselves at one point Armed Forces
reportedly fired tear
gas locals like this man carrying an
elderly woman in his arms now claim
they're not only being victimized by
drug gangs but also by the
military we're being displaced the
government sent the Mexican Army to
drive the people out of noeva America
see for yourself the people are fleeing
from their
homes when asked about the in Mexico's
president Andres Manuel Lopez obor
called on indigenous villagers in chapas
to place their trust in the country's
Armed
Forces we are tending to and protecting
the people the National Guard is there
chapas is Mexico's poorest state here
the combination of extreme poverty and
years of neglect by the government are
among the reasons deadly cels have
managed to take over entire swaths of
territory this propaganda video
published last year by the caloa cartel
shows what appears to be a cartel Parade
Where local residents were reportedly
forced to cheer on passing Vehicles the
viral video highlights just how much
influence and control the drug cartels
have in southern Mexico Manuel rapalo Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer